hey there it's Conan O'Brien welcome to
Conan O'Brien needs a friend
I'm chilling with my my best buds oh
wait no I'm not I'm here with Sona and
with Matt Gourley sorry for a second I
thought I was with my best friends ever
Sona and I are best but yeah we're best
yeah I can sense that you guys have a
very strong connection yeah I don't get
it myself day one yeah really yeah I
mean even before that I think just
before all space and do you think you
knew each other in past lives yeah
impossible we ran into each other where
we grew up that's right we grew up a
city apart from each other yeah no I
meant like thousands of years ago when
you guys doing the equivalent of a
podcast near some ancient ruins no she
was Cleopatra and I was Mark Anthony
yeah I love how in past lives everyone's
famous I know and I was not I've looked
into it oh I was always a guy holding a
shovel or being killed with a shovel
right throughout history
yes by you yeah I was killed by Napoleon
with a shovel and I was killed by
Cleopatra with a show it's surprising
you haven't been killed by a shovel yet
in this life yeah I've been attacked
many times with shovels but because
we're in the modern era I'm usually able
to get to my car quickly and the blows
slide ineffectually off the hood of my
car okay Sona are you comfortable
tonight today I'll say today but it
could be any time of day where we are
and I said tonight just to try and throw
the listener off oh okay I don't want
them to know we're in a windowless room
so it might as well be night time but it
is not we just started you were just
outside and it's bright and it's sunny
but it no I'm chilly you're chilly I am
yeah yeah me too okay I wanted to
address that because
um I don't care
and I wanted to make that clearer
because just before we started to record
someone did this whole thing about I'm
not I'm kind of cold and we all said
well do you want to go get a jacket or
something and you said no no no but I'm
just I'm slightly slightly chilly but
not enough for I'm thinking this is
something I'm supposed to be thinking
about I Conan O'Brien and then you bring
it back while we're recording your final
conversation back to it I want people to
know what a silly fuss budget you are I
want to talk about how it is cold in
this studio but not cold enough to like
put on a jacket but it's cold where you
need some sort of layer on top of what
you're wearing how about this here is a
a tissue
right next to me what if I just drape
these I'm draping them onto Sona right
now thank you there I just draped that
shoulder should be
0.04 percent warmer do you know how many
times if you've said you were like cold
or something I'll be like oh my God I
gotta get a jacket because that was my
job as an assistant yeah as if sorry I
always cared about your comfort
even even I'm not really uh buying that
one I did you didn't famously didn't I
didn't always but I did sometimes again
one of my favorite pictures is us
somewhere and there I'm taking a selfie
with like 15 people a whole series of
selfies and in the foreground someone is
ignoring me and having the largest pour
of white wine I've seen in North America
God bless you well I mean all I'm saying
is there have been times when you've
you've been like oh I I'm you know
chilly or I'm warm and I would have been
like oh okay I don't think so I honestly
don't think so and listen you know I
love you but I honestly don't think so
that is not your instinct yeah now I've
seen that it's your instinct with your
children right but no it's not it was
never I care about their comfort more
than I've ever cared about yours but I
also I birthed them I worked for you but
I didn't birth you so you know what
there was a huge misunderstanding here I
could have sworn that you birthed me
what are you talking about we all know
that was working for him as painful as
birthdays yeah
every day
[Laughter]
push on a push just get through the day
with Conan push I have a standing
appointment with anesthesiologist just
to come in here yeah anesthesiologist
you had trouble with it it was because
I'm anesthesiology
all I'm saying is uh I was a little
chilly and no one I mean people just
like Matt offered me his jacket blade
was like I could go get yours and you
didn't do anything or say it I don't
have a jacket with me but you have a
comfy looking sweater I do I wore a
sweater I just thought you know what I
saw a banshees administer and I've
decided to wear sweaters a lot now and I
want to I want to dress uh like everyone
in in banshees of initial it's
I'm gonna get a little stove that burns
Pete yeah and I'm gonna have it in the
konico offices and I'm gonna burn Pete
like they do in the Old Farm
because you're turning into the
caricature you pain of me yeah but okay
so what you know maybe secretly I'm just
jealous really yeah I think you're you
have cool stuff
what's he doing what's happening I'm
sorry you have I think your house is
really cool what is happening I am
uncomfortable yes it shouldn't be I I'm
admitting to you that sometimes when I
attack somebody for something it's
because secretly I envy what they
possess you have a really cool arts and
crafts home in Pasadena oh no where it's
140 degrees in the summer
part of me that envies arts and crafts
huh yeah it's a style Craftsman
yeah I didn't know that yeah it could
also mean that his uh his house was
constructed by children that's true
during a half hour period yeah it was
fingerpainted
yeah it is now that Glenn's running yeah
you have a nice uh very nice setup let's
move on I didn't I didn't that make you
uncomfortable yeah yeah you're still an
incredible dork okay okay here we go
that's better uh Terra Firma we're back
where we need to be and Sona if you're
you're in any way need anything please
let us know I don't like the way you
why'd your voice have to change just to
be nice because I'm making fun of you
yeah you turn into that's why Ricardo's
boss Lucille
Lucille